you
well hello goes up with her stocking
here actually my name is Brittany and
game I work on the building team at
Google and the compiler has been told
change particularly I work on GCC go I'm
very and tailor
ian land sailer I suppose and last what
goes I go for time and talk to a lot of
people about GCC go and I started learn
that general information when TCC go is
not available apparently no one actually
knows where it came from why it exists
or why it's actually useful so I thought
I'd be interesting to talk about these
sorts of things that's those questions
now let's talk about the future TCC go
and some of the improvements we've added
to it over the last two years since I've
been working at before so the first
question you might ask yourself is what
is easy together and the answer that is
it's just a go compiler that leverages
GCC for his compilation power things of
like things like optimizations and
cogeneration it was written by England's
Taylor and it's currently maintained by
him but informally its own end the other
go compiling so people know about the go
compiler and the GCC go with the other
go to compile ever so I'll accept that
name as well it's okay GCC goes kind of
little bit a tongue twister anyways but
really what easy to go is it's a
compiler quantum / go written in C++
that targets GCC and so the diagram kind
of breaks down with a bit so I'm talking
about GCC go and I'm really talking
about is this go funding that contains a
variety of tools including a parser
importer exporter some passes that do
semantic analysis will go code and also
our on with mutation of the go runtime
itself so when you actually invoke DCC
go if you
we've done that it was actually done
that but if you ever done that you
actually okay back there something
that's cool yeah what you actually are
doing is you're passing it go source
coding to the go front-end and what its
gonna do is translate that into
GCC's intermediate representation that's
called dimple new we feed this dimple
into GCC and it magically produces some
optimized binary that's just to go is
and that's how it works if you don't
understand any of this or you don't
really you never heard of this before
don't worry because turns out the go
team had no idea this was either when it
first came out according to the coin the
live feed this showed up at the door
would a fully working compiler and I
like to imagine what that looked like
and so I had the visualization of go
Foreman being produced the course
representation this is in actually
creating the entire go source tree on
one day or something he's that kind of
person
so that's a cool project but why would
someone write it go compiler in C++ that
targets GCC and it's kind of hard to see
the reason behind it now now the go p--
the go compiler then the tool chain are
actually really sophisticated but we
need to go back in time actually to win
the go compiler there just to go with
you least and look at the state of time
then so one reason why you might want to
GCC go is support meeting architectures
so looking back to Andy see goes
released in 2009 the go compiler
supported for architectures that are
major namely 386 x64 arm there are some
power work being done there
meanwhile the same time DCC go 2009
supports 45 architectures officially and
28 architectures unofficially so by
leveraging DCCC but leverage of ECC we
actually get all these architectures for
free basically and so we actually have
very little work writing architects
reports for new architectures because
it's already there GCC so that's one
reason why we might want to use
difficult less compiler that goes to GCC
another reason is cogeneration so TCC is
been around for almost 30 years now and
they've spent all that time working on
code analysis optimizations and
generation whereas go compiler recently
have been looking for this kind of stuff
but it's not very sophisticated yet the
only work we had right now is Keith
Randle's work on making the go I said
they're making the go compiler you have
to say at the back end so like leverage
what leverage it takes you see we
actually don't spend a lot of time
trying to produce Ultima binaries you
see see already has hundreds of passes
that it takes on Gimple code to actually
make binaries elsewhere and third reason
I like to say it's kind of a flaw
thoughtful reason and it's this idea of
technical honesty so when you have one
implementation of a certain product it's
really easy to believe that well it's
bug free every feature works inside of
there's nothing wrong with this right
soon as you have to any different ideas
you start
it'll do the same thing anymore so one
of them is wrong or the test vacation is
wrong so I guess the the point here is
that once you have distinct the
plantations you start to you think it's
it's this easy I try figure out where
they came from so the title of that one
of the implementations of the compilers
is wrong in some way or it could be the
language spec itself is not clear in
situations and we found situational use
needs to go so if you're from polymer
maintainer you're a language spec writer
this is a really great process for you
it's often automatic and invalidate my
designs right
but the thing by another way as well if
you're a user of these two proven pilers
you want to do the one that didn't rate
the better code for your project ideal
and so as soon as people start using my
compiler because didn't write better
code the other compiler is now forced to
keep up with me they have to keep the
same features that I do and so if you
end up getting is this kind of feature
parity with in compilers where they copy
each other's ideas and the big idea here
is that overall the result is better
compilers that generate better binaries
and as it's like and as it keeps going
and you kind of get this virtuous cycle
where now my compiler generates as good
as code as the other compiler maybe
better and as soon as I do better has to
do better and so on and so forth so for
the user how do these two composite view
each other means that you get better
binaries overall which we wanted so now
that we understand what Jesus ego is and
why it's useful maybe why you'll want to
use it let's kind of step back in look
at some of the improvements we've added
over the last couple of years to make
GCC go a better compiler overall here's
some things that I've been working on
over the last year at least and one of
them is the DOE front-end little bit
earlier
thing that we actually use to generate
this Gimple code between TCC it no
longer depends on DCC anymore instead
GCC it's on the side now the girlfriend
provides a backhand interface that GCC
implements and so this is kind of a
little code snippet that demonstrates
the ID here so we're trying to do here
is generation code for an entry constant
so imagine the statement a colon equals
one a is like a variable the one is some
kind of constant expression and we're
generating the code for that constant
expression and it's that simple and easy
to go so in the past you used the Gimple
or the GCC internal API which uses this
tree value stuff to actually build this
integer constant but now we just
actually rely on the back end whoever
that is could be any compiler to
actually give us whatever and reconquer
class next question is and then the
backing very simple
do you want so this is actually really
major what significant about this is
that now the girlfriend can be plugged
into any C++ compiler back up so I mean
I think there's one's thinking LLVM
right now because I am - that's really
the idea is that now we can actually use
to go up on anything other compilers
that might come to exist in the future
that's important because to go primary
it does a lot of the work that we need
going it's important is generating the
code a second thing that's really
important is jesusito now it builds the
go tool by default which is pretty
awesome if you ever use GCC in the path
of GCC go in it becomes really annoying
once you have to actually build large
libraries you have to know a lot about
what to include what source code where
the source code lives that what
libraries to include yet but also to
worry about blinking up big files
together it's a lot of nastiness there
but the go tool is easy to use you can
type go build go run go test and it just
works on a management right so now
whatever compiler you actually install
like um flip the go tools now you have
this one single way to build go source
code across multiple compilers and you
don't even notice there's no difference
here only difference you see here is
that go version the report's GCC go has
the actual compiler and no one else
knows the difference the cones the Sam
if you want to pass flags to GCC go
there's a - you see C go flags option
here I'm passing F to go optimize
allocations
so if you are you know using they change
distribution at DCC go or you have your
own source that you're building I
recommend trying a thousand you find me
brother
it should we're just as well as it goes
wall another thing that we recently
added with basic analysis we go running
so in the patch you see go they're not
actually run escape analysis on code I
mean so the analysis that we have in DC
in DC go right now is implementation of
a paper called escape analysis and Java
written by John Choi before I go into
details about that let me kind of
discuss what scape analysis isn't why
it's important so escape analysis you
want to analyze variables to find out
their life time exceeds the lifetime of
the function to declare down so for
example if the variable is declared the
function and it lives longer than that
function lives
that means the memories being used
outside of that function which means you
can't actually allocate the memory on
the staff you have the allocated on the
heap somewhere
I think that's fine
anyway so let me try to explain each one
of them very simply so chuggins it's
pretty straightforward the idea is you
take your entire program and you make a
call graph the call graph models the
connection between all colors and all
colleagues so it's not free in this
example main is a function that gets
called but it's a caller of F so f is
the qaule of me
so my connections rapper model is just
relationship so basically here with
these boxes at the main am I call Brad
there would be a there be a link between
F in the main saying that they're
connected in some way particularly that
main calls F after you make your call
graph in the chalk with them you then
want to go dairy function in your call
graph and make let's call a connection
graph a connection graph models the
connectivity between all objects and
every function so what you're actually
modeling here is what objects lifetimes
are laid to each other
remember the entire appoint of this is
that we actually analyze the lifetime of
certain very less than a function right
at the bottom after you have that
connection graph then you do this kind
of reachability analysis because we say
that if the lifetime of some object
exceeds the lifetime of its function
than anything connects to also exceeds
left on this function so here there's no
an action a little very boring a stock
has to go somewhere especially a point
and particularly their lifetime to now
relate to each other
so the founder I in function f now it
speaks because of our analysis so we're
also able to see us to between the
colors and the Pauly D so you realize
that that we called halfway so now so do
our analysis we'll look and see that
mobile touches I to take what will
scarcely keep therefore as hippie so
with this analysis turned on who'd
actually realized that they cannot be
allocated on the stack that's missing on
if that were not the case that we can
actually allocate a on the stack
somewhere and save an allocation so it's
all kind of memory allocation machines
and you get punched loves the basket
later because I'm really kind of going
right classic there's a lot more detail
than us mister very simple example ok so
the other things we've been doing to
actually improve the DCC go compiler
over the last couple years but we're
still kind of behind when it comes to
feature parity with the go compiler and
so I'm gonna talk a little bit about
what we're doing to keep up and what
some of the problems were facing art so
one of the problems right now is that
the right time the garbage collector for
GCC go or just out of date we're not in
parody yet so GCC going one time is
actually a multi version of the goal one
point three one time recalled ballpoint
fives new at least in August so we're
there's reasons for this as well there
are a lot of changes from the home funk
tater won't go on point for it
particularly in going point for most of
the wrong time as you're written in
goggle and so thisis ego we have a
modified version of the C runtime that
used to be used in the 1.3 and so it's
not very straightforward to actually
just accept that code without
modification take a little bit of work a
lot of differences the goal point for
they actually changed the way that God
reflector they've changed some time
formation the garbage collector expects
from the compiler so the compiler
generates whenever the power does an
allocation it generates type information
and the garbage talk expects to see that
type of information so we can understand
what type something is on the hungry
heap or the stack or whatever and both
more change that type info so it's
actually very difficult to modify DCC go
to be up to one point for it without
modifying these couple of things but
those things aren't actually the most
important problems one of the biggest
problems is that goal point 3 changed
the way that the stack micro Sol 0.3 or
0.2 at least there is this idea of
segmented stacks or splits that's
basically when a stack got beyond a
certain boundary you split it into two
stacks or make another stack and connect
to each other since 1.3 we actually have
contiguous stacks now so the stack just
kind of grows and you make a new stack
that twice as big or something you need
a new stack and copy all the pointers
over so in order to do that kind of
you'd be able to keep control you need
Mabel to precisely know what's on the
stack at all times they keep track of to
the entire time and to do that you need
a stack now that records the location of
all life variables given somewhere in
the stack so you look at some place in
exactly say it's just still being used
somewhere there's a pointer that points
of this I don't know and then a lot of
the Grunch likely to be precise about
what's actually on the stack and any
given point and because the god factor
knows what's on the second day to employ
them you actually grow the stack too
large
you have to make a new stack you can
copy all the pointers over you can
readjust the points that point to that
and you can actually keep track of
everything as if nothing happened the
problem we have right now though is that
none of these see compliant one of the C
compiler is such as GCC or LLVM actually
have support for stack knives so we
can't actually enable continuous taxes
to go until we have this so that's one
of the things holding us back right now
I think Ian's gonna actually try to look
at that but it's gonna take a lot of
work so until we do that or actually be
behind on the time to go run time for a
long time
switching something else so looking at
the teacher though one thing we want to
do is actually take advantage of our
improvements so like I said recently the
go front is now totally distinct from
GCC there's there's no dependency there
so now we can use that go front anyway
it's much less compiler and particularly
with LLVM so we can make this LLVM go
and call it another other go compiler so
many others on and have opportunities
they'll be my code is being accepted in
a lot of places so I mentioned pinnacle
here which is a portable Native Client
which is some kind of Chrome extension
or whatever that allows you to sounds
Brian yeah that allows you to it's
allows you to run native code in the web
so that's an opportunity but there's
also opportunities know the in general
people are moving albums I are they
think it's actually a lot easier to work
weight over all certain companies are
actually doing interesting applications
with it like you're seeing things like
in script in that take a low V Mir terms
of dollar script etc etcetera so if we
can actually target all of them as a
backing up our
I mean there's a lot opportunities that
open the door for us or that certainly
show up there and I think one of the
last things that we need a lot of help
on probably is OS support I think right
now almost X and Windows the story is
really and Windows it doesn't really
work at all you see just two guys
working Windows very well at all you
mean like men gcw it something 50w on OS
X I feel like there's a lot of failures
so these one of those things that we
need an expert in caulk wait we don't
actually know anything about these OSS
anyway that being said that's really all
I had this is just like a really general
overview of GCC go
so hopefully you get understanding of
what these ago actually is in general
you want more detailed questions you can
ask
okay there any questions I know that was
really good please think I can go back
yes so you mentioned now and we'll be
able to go it's not just an idea or are
people actually working on that sir
okay so that an idea that things were
working on it so Ella Bianco is its idea
to me there is the project elevator for
a different approach
so there's another compiler called go
Titans written by rock reasoner and ll
go visas go types too far salt as a
cappella flying and news LLVM as a
package so there are products of using
opium as a back engine planter so it is
real loving televideo time any other
questions yes
I'm looking at here easy
I know that canonically is LVM today so
I know that doctors
that's our doctors DC go so this again
okay
yeah I'm not recovered users I mean
there's IBM there's uh missing
yeah other big companies I really know
there's not really a little good with
much yes
zero goal do not like is it just to help
you convince that
right the language
fancy
power always there
so the question was they're here for
mouth or a tsetse girl I saw a chair
that's a good chair black answer Wow I'm
not I'm not gonna make like a chair
so there's not a clear roadmap
I don't believe other than trying to
take some of the issues I mentioned
earlier but there are other reason CDC
to get other than to prove that the
flowers are actually correct another
thing a CCC CCC generates really big
hook over also the tsetse go from the
other day with the go compiler it should
generate a lot better to the mother of
binaries for a girl in general and that
will hopefully inspire if you go
compiler team to sorry
we have multiple powers and with Sona
and enjoyed it if the reason that were
completing our states because we were
able to try things so the questions we
have the Jackson however which showed
you know really interesting something
research that you would not
so I don't know if it will has the same
attention but going since like out of
the equal one generic area to my
so right now that's so right now there's
no goal for fermentation right it's just
to keep up with the go compiler this
Punk because we're so far behind after
that there's a lot of opportunity for
that kind of ten so there are people
have been working on things like
generics
we tried PCC go I've had the easier time
with the phrase exactly so theses ago is
there for it to be experiments on we
don't
we don't say you shouldn't do that but
right now the focus of the DCC go at
apology which is me in here and
basically is to actually get up to being
your people to go kamiya at that point
it's fine thank you some actual
comparisons to figure out what's forward
explore but that's it so for example
escape routes we're talking about here's
the toilet fermentation you don't want
inside the go compiler and so at some
point once we get the parity with the go
complete to go one time watch they will
do an apples apples comparison and say
which one's actually better and so we're
hoping to improve some of them some of
the basic tool are sort of based
authorization to the book compilers by
trying to permutation seen what some
better
you guys had to try it sometime
literature is a huge number
so well say the question was about
skipping bosses they expect in our
collection and maybe in general public
life in car collection so I want to say
I'm not a confrontational person
I rather talk to a big Hudson about that
kind of thing I don't want to say
I was finally given I don't but those
game analysis towards garbage collection
this gift analysis is kind of known as
compile time for our collection it
actually just over added another
collector
we're looking find places where you say
new or you take the addresses in
variable that don't actually escaped
from the function as declare them then
we can actually avoid allocating on key
between the collector has just the boy
is collecting entire round so turning
out stamp analysis surely make a car
collector run better a box where it
should have less overhead the car
collector that's the big idea won't you
be able to switch different kind that's
true yeah maybe but right now we have
great how the compiler is dedicated to
making it easy to run these things in
terms of where Java which you might see
is a lot of people are specialized in
learning knobs for garbage collection we
don't really want that we wanted to be
simple these garbage collection and I
worry
who really gets in the way of what
you're doing which operating application
writing some tools so I think that's one
D I guess that's your question okay
okay well thank you all for did we
chance to talk if it's too confusing
please after later if you have customers